اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من تلي ابيب اهلا
بكم الجيش الاسرائيلي يعلن مقتل 24 من
ضباطه وجنوده واصابه عشرات في معارك قطاع
غزه خلال 24 ساعه كتائب القسام تعلن تفجير
غرفه في قوه اسرائيليه ومقتل ثلاثه من
افرادها واصابه عدد اخر غرب مدينه خانيونس
وسرايا القدس تؤكد تفجير دبابه اسرائيليه
وقصف تمركز لجنود واليات اسرائيليه من
القطع وتعليقا على عمليه المغازي نتنياهو
يقول ان اسرائيل عاشت امس احد اصعب الايام
منذ اندلاع الحرب ووزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
يصف ما جرى بالضربه القويه ويقول ان مقتل
24 عسكريا ليس بالامر الهيل اما الوزير
بمجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي بيني جانس فقال
انها كارثه في حين وصف زعيم المعارضه يا
اير لفيد الاخبار الوارده من غزه بالميره
والتي لا تطاق قوات الاحتلال تقصف
بالمدفعيه مخيمات النازحين في منطقه
المواصي جنوب خان يونس وتقتل عددا من
قاتليها وشهداء في قصف نفذته دبابه
اسرائيليه على سياره مدنيه كانت متجهه من
خان يونس الى رفح والامر تحذر من ان 570
الف شخص في غزه يواجهون جوعا كارثيا
وكاميرا الجزيره ترصد تفاقم الوضع
الانساني مع تعذر دخول المساعدات الى غزه
واضطرار السكاني لاستخدام الاعلاف لتوفير
الطعام قصف امريكي بريطاني على مواقع
للحوثيين في اليمن واشنطن تؤكد انها
استهدفت منصات صواريخ ومسيرات ومخازن
اسلحه وانه تم بدعم استرالي كندي هولندي
بحريني بريطانيا تقول ان القصف سيوجه ضربه
اخرى لمخزونات الحوثيين وقدرتهم على تهديد
التجاره العالميه في حين قالت جماعه انصار
الله الحوثيين ان الضربه شملت صنعاء
والبيضاء وتعز الى
اللقاء